bonsoir bienvenue ça vous regarde en
direct ravi de vous retrouvez donc trois
jours les français sont appelés aux
urnes mais parmi les douze candidats en
lice un treizième s'invite dans la
course l'abstention c'est la crainte
dans tous les états majors tous les
indicateurs montrent qu'elle risque
d'être forte désengagement des intérêts
des actes politiques comment interpréter
ce refus de choisir l'abstention cet
inconnu qui pourrait à faire tout
basculer c'est notre grand débat dans un
instant avec nos invités notre grand
témoin lui est historien élu à
l'académie française l'année dernière
une partie de son oeuvre la plus
politique et rassembler aujourd'hui dans
la prestigieuse collection bouquins sous
ce titre ce côté obscur du peuple ce
peuple dont tous se réclament peut aussi
être autoritaire et mais la dictature et
la xénophobie nous enseigne est il alors
le recevoir avant le choix des français
alors marine le pen peut gagner prend un
relief particulier pascal ory est avec
nous ce soir enfin de l'os cannes ce
soir l'ultime stratégie des petits
candidats avec brandon roy rete le front
anti macro qui stupéfie la presse
étrangère c'est ce que nous explique
richard verdi et puis l'oeil de blacko
bien sûr la chronique quotidienne le
carnet de campagne de stéphane blakowski
voilà pour le menu
c'est parti
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs drôle de sentiment à
trois jours du vote comme l'impression
que tout est joué d'avancé
et quand même temps une grosse surprise
pourrait surgir une élection à haut
risque titre l'ops les risques d'un
scrutin incertain en une du monde avec
cette grande inconnue qui pourrait
changer peut-être la donne le niveau de
l'abstention on en parle avec vous ce
soir roland cayrol bonsoir merci d'être
là vous êtes politologue l'un des plus
fins observateurs de nos grands rendez
vous électoraux et puis l'auteur aussi
d'un documentaire diffusé sur cette
antenne sur lcp en mars dernier
abstention premier parti de france point
d'interrogation c'est toujours
disponibles d'ailleurs on réglait sur
notre chaîne youtube bonsoir ce tueur
watchou stewart show bienvenue sur ce
plateau vous dirigez les études
politiques et opinions à viavoice vous
êtes l'auteur avec frédéric dabi d'un
ouvrage remarqué la fracture comment la
jeunesse d'aujourd'hui fait sécession
c'était aux éditions les arènes enfin
bon soir stéphane bern est en soin ravi
de vous retrouver sur ce plateau êtes
journaliste rédacteur en chef délégué et
directeur de la rédaction ouest-france
de paris alors je le dis évidemment
c'est une élection phare c'est un rendez
vous majeur pour la politique française
et pourtant près d'un électeur sur trois
on va regarder ça dans le détail avec
vous mais grosso modo c'est ça pourrait
s'abstenir avant de vous entendre sur
les causes sur les conséquences et sur
les solutions on va faire d'abord un
petit tour d'horizon par les
abstentionnistes on va d entendre mêmes
chiffres à l'appui mais alors
résignation ou colère le premier tour de
cette élection présidentielle s'annonce
comme l'un des moins suivis par les
électeurs 29 % d'abstention d'après le
dernier sondage de l'ifop largement au
dessus des 22,2 pour cent de 2017 et qui
pourrait donc surpassé le record de 28
4% en 2002 qu'est ce que ça va vraiment
changer pour moi au quotidien je me
lèverai le matin giraud boulot est ce
que je serai mieux payé est ce que je
paierais moins d'impôts nous le
promettent à chaque fois on n'a jamais
rien vu vingt ans plus tard les
critiques n'ont pas changé moi c'est la
meilleure solution il faut s'abstenir
pour leur faire voir qu'il nous
intéresse
et en plus on n'est pas je sais pas je
trouve qu'ils sont pas venus au contact
jean aucun candidat qui ne représente
vraiment que ce qui est vraiment avec
nous l'abstention touche surtout les
foyers les plus modestes 41 % d'entre
eux pourrait ne pas aller voter dimanche
selon doxa dans ce quartier populaire
d'orléans la politique est bien loin des
préoccupations du quotidien les
élections oui
chacun
et pas filmé j'oublie même sentiment
chez les plus jeunes parmi les 18-24 ans
seule une personne sur deux est sûrs
d'aller voter la raison des candidats
pas assez en phase avec leurs attentes
on parle de la retraite on repousse la
retraite mais on parle pas du dix huit
arrières on sait que les jeunes
travaillent plus mais on leur en faut
pas plus de travail en tête contournée
par exemple étudiants qu'on a des sages
à la fin on est diplômé travail ça c'est
la réalité
sur les réseaux sociaux les campagnes
s'intensifie objectif combattre
l'abstention qui recule très modestement
dans cette dernière ligne droite avant
l'élection
elles ont recommencé avec le sondeur que
vous êtes sur air chaud d'abord près
d'un électeur sur trois pourrait bouder
les urnes on a choisi 29% mais en gros
c'est à peu près le chiffre moyen qui
revient dans les instituts 28 à 30%
comment on la mesure si près du vote
l'abstention est ce qu'on demande aux
gens êtes vous certains d'aller voter ou
est ce que vous leur posez la question
oui ou non allez vous vous abstenir
plusieurs modalités effectivement il ya
normalement une échelle à dire que vous
vous demandez de sur la certitude
d'aller voter entre 0 et 10 et plus
effectivement on peut analyser par par
tranche de deux certitudes ou non
d'aller ou pas voter ce qui me semble
intéressant dans la dent ce taux
d'abstention qui va être effectivement
et qui est mesuré autour de qui va être
on ne sait pas vers le quartier est
mesurée actuellement autour de autour de
30% il dit il dit trois choses et votre
reportage montre assez bien le le panel
un peu représentative des des idées que
portent les français les déterminants de
l'abstention la première chose c'est
finalement une campagne qui n'apportent
pas de bonnes idées les programmes des
candidats ne vous conviennent pas loin
des préoccupations deuxième élément est
2e déterminant sur sa a précisément
parce qu'on pourrait aller dire à chaque
élection c'est cette campagne là qui est
quand même très particulière où ces voix
là à chaque élection on me répond pas à
ma demande alors vous avez raison sauf
que cette élection a là quand même comme
inédit qu'elle n'a pas su je dirais à
mettre en place cette conversation
idéologique c'est à dire qu on a un
sentiment et c'est un deuxième deuxième
partie de ma réponse que les français
ont plutôt l'impression qu'il n'ya pas
eu de débat de fond de débat de
programme de débats d'idées donc
finalement ça amplifie lui tendance de
fond qui amène effectivement les
français à se dire que finalement il n'y
a rien aujourd'hui qui puisse leur
convenir on est vraiment sur une
défaillance de l'offre politique perçu
un chiffre pourrait vite pour essayer
d'objectiver tout ça vous avez quand
même 76 % des français actuellement qui
considère que cette campagne n'apporte
pas de bonnes idées dont vous voyez il
ya quand même un élément
autour de l'idéologie des idées des
programmes qui est assez déterminant à
ce qu'elle progresse aussi dans toutes
les catégories de la population
cette abstention vous ne mesurez ça
alors cette abstention c'est vrai
qu'elle n'est pas forcément très
homogène on en parlera il ya des
catégories qui traditionnel d'ailleurs
qu'ils s'abstiennent play offs et
sociologie de l'abstention il ya un
profil d'abstentionnistes qui ce qui se
dégage pense que l'un des marqueurs
forts c'est effectivement cette
génération peut être un peu abstention
qui est en train d'émerger peut-être un
peu plus qu'auparavant c'est à dire les
jeunes on voit une abstention qui pour
l'instant est assez en attention massive
des 18 30 mais effectivement il ya une
forme de voile à 2 d'opinion publique un
peu usé aussi par sept par cette vie
politique et surtout sur ce qu'elle
propose aujourd'hui on terme en terme
d'offre politique alors roland cayrol
cette tentation de l'abstention est plus
forte a fait présidentielle qu'aux
précédentes est-ce que c'est grave
d'abord on va voir que sera le vrai taux
au fond il ya une vague
absolument irrépressible montée de
l'abstention dans tous nos pays
notamment celui-ci à toutes les formes
d' élections y compris à la
présidentielle mais à la présidentielle
on vote quand même beaucoup plus parce
que même si les gens sont désenchantés
par rapport à la politique sert à rien
etc il ya cette idée que c'est la mère
des batailles c'est la reine des
batailles la présidentielle donc à la
limite sur votre cas une seule bassett à
celles ci ont reproduit à peu près le
taux record de 28 % seulement
d'abstention bah ça prouvera que la
courbe n'a pas monté alors on va la
regarder quand même parce qu'on est là
quand même l'impression qu'on a une
tendance de long terme depuis 2007 où
l'abstention était très faible 16 2%
elle ne cesse d'augmenter cette
abstention la grande question c'est
est-ce qu'elle va dépasser le record de
2002 28,4 vous y croyez je n'en sais
rien je pense que on est dans le moment
où ça se décide où çà et là la plupart
des gens qui ce qui hésite il se décide
dans les trois derniers jours voire même
le dernier jury a traditionnellement
dans les sondages autour de 10 à 15%
c'est énorme 2 gens qui se disent qu'ils
ont fait leur choix le matin même jour
du vote vous qui avait travaillé sur
cette question là c'est une démission ou
c'est un acte politique un message
envoyé aux politiques en leur disant je
ne veux pas de vous et c'est une manière
un outil aussi que peut donner la
démocratie franchement c'est d'abord
c'est ça en petite partie la plus grosse
partie c'est de l'indifférence je n'y
crois plus il y en a marre ils nous font
ils viennent faire les beaux devant nous
pendant la campagne électorale ils nous
promettent des tas de choses ça va être
tous les jours noël et puis dès que
c'est fini il s'occupe plus de nous le
peuple salaire est égal il s'occupe de
faire leur carrière et de leur petite
magouille voilà c'est plutôt une espèce
de désintérêt des anches hantées par
respect de la colère politique plus que
de la colère plus que de la rébellion
contre le système c'est un petit peu le
cas cela ils le disent fortement ils le
disent aux sondeurs mais ça n'est qu'une
minorité des abstentionnistes la vérité
c'est qu'on arrive progressivement à ce
que des catégories entières on arrive
près ça une chose étonnante c'est que le
suffrage universel à force d'être
associés aux abstentionnistes se met
ressembler au suffrage censitaire de
jadis c'est de plus en plus les gens qui
ont des moyens éducatifs et des moyens
financiers dans la hiérarchie sociale
qui sont les électeurs fidèles les
autres se détache un peu de cette
société il ya une sorte de fracture dans
l'abstention fracture sociale aussi
stéphane bern et quand on regarde qui
qui s'abstient le plus on l'a dit les
jeunes mais aussi les classes les moins
aisés ça veut dire que c'est ça creuse
encore plus cette fracture d'une
certaine façon et qu'on n'est pas
seulement dans la question d'un rejet
alors moi je suis complètement d'accord
avec ce qui vient dire roland cayrol sur
le fait que plus ça va et plus on a
l'impression que le suffrage universel
en train de se transformer en suffrage
censitaire c'est à dire que au bout du
bout qu'est ce qui va se passer dans les
faits c'est que s'il ya plus qu les
riches ou ceux qui vont bien qu'ils
votent on a effectivement pâle par la
même façon de gérer notre notre
démocratie sur le sueur sur ces
questions là ce que je sais que je
trouve étonnant si voulez moi ce que je
trouve très frappant c'est que à mon
avis
ça doit être une des présidentielles qui
depuis très longtemps si ce n'est pour
la première fois sous cette vème
république où on est appelés à voter à
un moment où les enjeux sont aussi fort
je viens ce qui nous attend est énorme
le contexte est délirant on est en
pleine pandémie pouvait la guerre aux
portes de l'europe le giec qui nous
annonce qu'on a plus de trois ans en
fait pour pour réactiver les choses on a
une économie qui est pas en grande forme
des inégalités qui se creusent enfin il
ya il se passe énormément de choses je
pense que c'est vraiment le moment où on
a besoin de se poser la question de
savoir à qui on confie les clés du
camion pour les sections division que
ces causes là les français méconnaissent
la jeunesse s'engage mais qu'elle ne
comprend pas l'utilité du vote ça ne
veut pas dire qu'il n'y a pas
d'engagement on voit d'ailleurs dans la
rue lajeunesse pour le climat il ya une
forme de d'adhésion à des causes mais
plus à l'utilité de la démocratie
élective totalement d'accord avec vous
là la jeune génération est très
politisée elle est très conscientisé
elle s'est engagé énormément mais elle
considère que le vote ne lui correspond
plus on l'a bien vu dans les extraits
que vous avez publié fois que vous avez
diffusé sont très intéressants on a un
bon succès d'année un bon résumé d'un
problématique les gens qui je me sens
pas représenté ça sert à rien on nous
oublie mais j'insiste le paradoxe c'est
que les enjeux sont justes fenomeno
qu'on peut pas dire qu'en fait on est on
est mal représentée ou que ça correspond
à rien je suis désolé quand vous avez
douze candidats avec un spectre hyper
large qui va des 2 2 de deux candidats
trotskistes enfin de l'extrême gauche à
l'extrême droite vous avez tous sur le
tapis je veux dire il ya quand même
moyen de faire son choix et de se poser
les bonnes questions or le problème si
vous voulez et ça concerne pas que les
jeunes c'est l'ensemble des citoyens de
ce pays je trouve qu'il ya beaucoup de
paresse c'est à dire que on a des
problèmes excusez moi de le dire
surtout des problématiques de pays
riches si vous voulez ou deux pays je
trouve qu'on vit dans un pays qui est
beaucoup trop sûr de sa vieille
démocratie et qui pensent qu'elle
fonctionne et c'est que tout va bien et
finalement on se dit bon à quoi bon
voter ça sert à rien euh moi je veux
bien mais quand on entend une partie du
discours qui consiste à dire il n'y a
pas eu de campagne et l'indigent pas
niveau je veux bien aussi mais en
réalité si vous voulez qu'elle ait
quelques elle devrait être notre
position en tant que citoyens et
citoyennes de ce pays c'est à dire que
c'est peut-être aussi à nous d'abord de
s'intéresser à ce qui se dit quand les
gens disent oui ils sont tous pareils il
n'ya pas l'intérêt moi je suis désolé je
ferais scola cet avocat avait cette
défiance qui est déjà là dessus je
regardais regarder ce qui a été produit
autour de cette campagne c'est à dire
quand on dit il n'ya pas de campagne
regardez ce qui a été produit autour de
cette campagne dans les journaux les
magazines à la télé les radios on nous
dit a pas de débat et enfin les
candidats on les voit matin midi et soir
ils font les matinales ils font les
soirs il ya des débats partout et la
campagne elle existe donc si le cet
espèce de rejet consiste à dire on sait
pas trop ça n'a pas l'intérêt il
s'occupa nous on voit pas ce qu'ils
veulent moi je suis désolé mais si vous
voulez savoir en deux clics vous pouvez
avoir le détail de chacun des programmes
franchement je être citoyen c'est pas
qu'une question de droit c'est aussi que
vous avez travaillé sur la question de
la jeunesse au fond de l'impression que
pour une partie de la jeunesse ça n'est
qu'un droit après tout le droit c'est on
peut l'utiliser on peut ne pas
l'utiliser cette dimension du devoir et
une éducation au vote à l'école
l'instruction civique elle n'est plus n
est plus du tout présentant dans la
société française je crois que ce que
vous avez dit est très juste dire que je
crois pas que ce soit une un désintérêt
ou une absence de prise de conscience
des enjeux qui explique finalement le
désamour et l'exil électorale des jeunes
que l'idée selon laquelle en tout cas
pour la jeunesse ce ne sera pas le
politique où les politiques qui
répondront de manière efficace aux
enjeux qu'ils identifient un exemple qui
parlera à la jeunesse et l'environnement
on nous a dit dans cette campagne on ne
parle pas assez d'environnement c'est la
raison pour laquelle les jeunes
éventuellement n'irait pas voter je
doute un peu de ça en tout cas il
faudrait nuancer parce que je pense pas
que ce soit l'absence de la thématique
dans le débat actuel encore qu'il
faudrait d'ailleurs en parler parce que
je pense que ça infuser l'on ne crois
pas qu'ils vont changer les choses ce ne
sont pas les représentent ce ne sera pas
dans le vote finalement que passeront
les solutions efficaces vous donne juste
un dernière une dernière tendance qui me
semblent importantes les jeunes il ya
une double logique sur la politique il
ya une logique du tous pourris c'est à
dire qu'effectivement 82% aujourd'hui
des 18 30 considèrent notre personnel
politique malhonnête c'est un état de
fait et à la logique et je pense qu'il
est beaucoup plus intéressante à
analyser du tous impuissants et je pense
que la question de la vanité du vote est
quelque chose aussi de centrales dans
cette abstention de la jeunesse qui ne
perçoit pas dans le politique l'acteur
je dirais le plus efficace pour agir et
changer des choses la vanité du vote
l'impuissance du politique c'est ça les
vrais moteurs au fond oui oui on a
longtemps considéré que voter était un
devoir civique il ya encore beaucoup de
gendre les plus de 60 ans qui pensent ça
qu'ils vont voter même si l'élection ne
passionne pas même si ça leur paraît pas
fondamental parce qu'ils ont suivi le
même chemin par rapport à la politique
que les plus jeunes mais ils pensent que
c'est un devoir civique ça en effet ça
n'existe plus si on demande aux gens qu
est ce que c'est les devoirs du citoyen
ils vont vous dire en premier pas jeter
des ordures dans la nature ils vont dire
des choses qui te concerne la protection
de l'environnement le vote ça arrive en
huitième dixième position pourquoi pour
ça parce qu'on voit pas le lien entre
les vrais problèmes qu'on est dur est ce
que mon vote va changer vous raconter au
fond un lent lady délitement du pacte
démocratique donc on va passer à la
phase des solutions comment ont
réconcilié on sent que c'est très
profond fatigue démocratique défiance
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire changer de
république peut-être vais vous poser la
question mais avant de savoir comment à
les réconcilier on va passer un extrait
de votre documentaire parce que dans les
familles justement pour illustrer au
fond une forme de fracture entre les
générations ça discutait regardez cet
extrait entre une mère de famille qui
tente et bien de convaincre sa fille
d'aller voter
allons un fontenay sous bois avec océane
étudiante
qui va avec sa mère retrouvé une vieille
amie de la famille le moins qu'on puisse
dire c'est qu'elles ne sont pas d'accord
sur l'abstention
voter c'est donner ton avis etc émettre
une opinion c'est faire partie de ça ne
change rien tutorat beaudonnet ton
opinion ça ne changera pas vous devriez
participer et se dire non on va faire
bouger les choses par les urnes en
passant aussi par le côté mais c'est un
truc c'est que toi tu pour toi tu veux
vous faire bouger les choses avec une
urne avec un petit bout de papier sur
laquelle tu vas être le nom de quelqu'un
mais c'est important mais pourquoi mais
parce que c'est ta voix mais ma voix ne
compte pas quand
on est des maillots millions la voix ne
compte pas parce que ça ne changera rien
mais ça fait 45 ans que c'est comme ça
mais non il ya des petites avancées j'ai
des petites en 40 ans et des petites
avancées mais mais juste parce que tu
t'es battu dehors pas parce que tu as
voté et bien c'est maintenant qu'il faut
que tu que tu participes homme qui peut
aisément votants devaient devenir
heureuse je vais mettre mon mieux
et là j'ai une bouffée de bonheur qui va
batailler c'est pas en votant que tu vas
devenir heureuse mettra une
participation de ne pas te laisser des
frissons quand tu veux en fait voter
voter c'est juste pas se laisser porter
c'est à dire que revendiquer dans la rue
c'est très très bien c'est très beau et
voter c'est pas si ses portes
voilà tout ou tiède ans est dans cet
extrait de vie quotidienne voyez tout y
est parce qu on voit bien que cette
je ne suis océane elle et elle croit des
choses politiques que ce qu'elle croit
pas c'est que son vote peut changer quoi
que ce soit avec en plus cette idée là
elle parle comme jeune que les jeunes
ils sont beaucoup moins nombreux que
tous les autres et que en tant que jeune
s ils pèseront pas non plus c'est
incroyable cette idée de peser un homme
une voix on a dit la démocratie le le
moins pire des systèmes finalement ça
pose des questions même sur notre
organisation collective alors quelle
solution va commencer par des solutions
un peu technique vous allez vous dire si
ça vous semble utile moderniser nos
modalités de vote alors il ya plein de
choses ici l assemblée on a beaucoup
travaillé l'inscription automatique sur
les listes électorales pour éviter de
faire la queue devant les commissariats
pour s'inscrire est évidemment sas
actualiserait quand on déménage la
possibilité de voter en cliquant sur un
bouton dans un bureau de vote plutôt que
de glisser le bulletin bien sûr yens
vote à distance le vote électronique
tout cet aspect là ça vous semble
répondre aux problèmes où on est à côté
de la plaque
je vais vous répondre alors je vais vous
répondre à côté mais vous allez voir en
fait je trouve qu'il ya le conseil
économique social et environnemental a
fait un travail remarquable sur la
question le ce en fait ils ont rendu un
avis il ya quinze jours sur l'abstention
et notamment ils ont étudié la question
cruciale de l'abstention des jeunes
qu'on vient de voir et la réponse du ce
il ya deux choses qui moi me paraissent
très intéressante c'est que 1 les
rapporteurs donc il y avait des y avait
des jeunes qui étaient associés
directement à ce travail des jeunes
citoyens des noeuds c'est aussi pour ça
que c'est intéressant hélas la première
réponse et dire attention on a un
problème avec cette histoire
d'abstention c'est que le disent nous
sommes convaincus que ce n'est pas une
question d'âge mais de génération je
m'explique des jeunes qui ne votent pas
à 18 ans aujourd'hui ils voteront pas
plus sarah 30 ils voteront pas plus à 40
ils voteront pas plus à 50 c'est ce que
disent ces jeunes eux mêmes qui sont
penchés sur la question merci commence
pas à voter maintenant ils sont perdus
pour la démocratie donc on est bien ça
dans la presse écrite on a le même
problème c'est à dire qu'à un lecteur
qui n'a pas appris à lire avec notre
journal petit deviendra pas un lecteur
plus tard c'est beaucoup plus difficile
de convertir déjà ensuite papier ou
internet papier c'est là c'est la même
chose dans ces démocraties ces jeux
complets je pense que s'il faut vraiment
avoir ça en tête parce que effectivement
si on trouve pas les solutions
rapidement on peut avoir un trou qui
peut nous coûter très cher qu'arriverait
bout des lésions premièrement et
deuxièmement e10 il n'y a pas de
solution miracle c'est à dire c'est pas
il n'y a pas une ou deux solutions le
ils ont proposé vingt-et-une proposition
en disant il faut les prendre comme un
package est dedans il ya des choses un
peu de technique comme la modernisation
du vote mais il ya aussi plus de
proportionnelle par exemple la
reconnaissance du combat l'abaissement
en fin mais je pense qu'ils ont raison
c'est à dire que c'est un ensemble voilà
en fait ils ont froid que tout le monde
a compris que sa série ce nom c'est un
ensemble mais je vais vous dire l'autre
faut avoir en tête c'est que cette
réforme là il faut la faire tout de
suite je ne sais pas qui va gagner la
présidentielle mais ça va être un des
pour moi c'est un des premiers chantiers
à mener c'est à dire que ces réformes là
il faut les faire tout de suite au début
du quinquennat alors elle se marie à la
fin ce qui va être chaud vous l'avez
rencontré aussi cette jeunesse qu'est ce
qu'ils attendent parce qu'on entend ce
mot de démocratie participative
d'associer le citoyen à la décision
publique démocratie directe carrément
proportionnelle voir changement de
république est ce que c'est vraiment le
le coeur de l'architecturé de nos
institutions qu'il faut changer ou si on
facilite c'est déjà ça
c'est vrai qu'on est passé cette
génération là elle illustre assez bien
ce passage un citoyen je dirais
consultatif un citoyen comme dirait un
des grands constitutionnalistes
citoyens normatif c'est à dire
qu'effectivement on a l'impression en
tout cas le sentiment qu'on est dans une
génération face à une génération qui a
besoin de prendre part à la décision et
ça je pense que c'est aussi soulevé une
question dont on n'a pas forcément
beaucoup parlé c'est à mon sens
peut-être même le coeur de cette ce
symptôme démocratique c'est la crise de
la représentativité qui n'est pas juste
expliqué par une question d'incarnation
dans des personnalités je pense qu'elle
expliquait aussi par une grammaire de la
société qui fait qu'à partir du moment
où vous sur personnalisé sans cesse ses
expériences de vie que finalement vous
vous adressez sans cesse à l'individu il
est difficile aujourd'hui pour nos
jeunes parfois de faire le compromis la
concession est de mettre une urne et de
finalement déléguer son pouvoir
berrah tiff d'action et l'aider même
d'un présentation où ce sont les
représentants qui n'ont peut-être pas
pouvoir les deux et je pense que c'est à
la fois et ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure c'est à dire cette question de
vanité l'impuissance perçu du personnel
politique mais c'est aussi le principe
même de la représentation qui je pense
est aujourd'hui remise en question par
une partie de la jeunesse et qu'il faut
absolument pas oublier crise de la
représentation je crois que trois choses
différentes brièvement la première c'est
que en effet il faut utiliser toutes les
rustines pour aider à l'acte
démocratique
si on prend l'exemple que vous avez
donnée de l'inscription c'est ahurissant
ma collègue céline braconnier a calculé
les non inscrits et les gens qui ne sont
pas inscrits dans la commune où yves
hinse a fait 12 millions de français
comment est-ce qu'une classe politique
dirigeante peut s'autoriser à ne pas
changer un système c'est quand même
incroyable c'est pire encore que
l'abstention s'est écarté en le sachant
des millions de français du vote
deuxième chose vous avez évoqué
l'instruction civique non il n'ya pas
d'instruction civique en france en terme
d' instruction politique
les enseignants voulant être neutre
c'est l'heureux devoirs de fonctionnaire
de la république ne veulent pas entrer
dans les notions de gauche de droite de
centre quels sont les enjeux de
l'élection en cours on leur parle
d'histoire des institutions d'histoire
de la démocratie c'est très bien mais
c'est pas ça qui aident à faire prendre
conscience des enjeux des gens qui ont
moins de 18 ans dans la foule vraiment
parlé d' instruction politique de
manière civique dans les établissements
scolaires et puis la troisième chose
c'est cette histoire de représentation
moi je crois que en effet la démocratie
représentative telle qu'elle est à bout
de souffle des parlements qui ne
représente pas le pays des parlements
qui n'ont pas de vraies décisions
pouvoir dans la décision à quoi tout ça
se rappelle qu'on est à l'assemblée
nationale donc qu'est ce que vous
proposez du traitement les députés
qu'est ce que ça veut dire je leur
prochain ça veut dire plus de
proportionnelle pour mieux représenter
sur mon labrousse ça veut dire donner
vraiment plus de pouvoir au parlement et
là il faut changer la constitution veut
dire tout ça il faut probablement aller
dans ce sens
6ème république ou pas je pas aux forces
et jean luc mélenchon les français s'en
fiche c'est pas l' arrangement
institutionnel c'est le donner le
sentiment qu'on l'ait représente mieux
et que ça donne un véritable débat
politique avec des choix qui sont
respectées mais la démocratie directe
je crois qu'elle est suffisamment à bout
de souffle cette démocratie
représentative pour non pas être
remplacé mais être complété par des
véritables mécanismes de démocratie
participative
on ne supporterait plus comme élève
comme salarié comme parent d'élève
d'être traité comme on l'était il ya 20
ou 30 ans comme des pions on veut avoir
son mot à dire sur les décisions qui
nous concernent qui concerne notre
avenir l'avenir de nos enfants
référendum direct c'est tout ce qu'on
veut le référendum d'initiative
citoyenne le référendum tout court la
participation aux conseils municipaux
tout ce que vous voulez mais tout ce qui
permet aux gens d'être directement
parties prenantes à la décision
oui complètement c'est à dire qu'il ya
en fait il ya un besoin et une envie de
participation qui est extrêmement fort
dans ce pays en fait on inviterait
politique et c'est pas vrai de dire que
les gens s'y intéressent plus c'est eux
on entend beaucoup l'argument de dire
attention au populisme cette idée que au
fond si un plus un plus un plus un tout
le monde participe dans des leoric
rappelez-vous les gilet jaune tout ça
vous dit non il faut tenir compte de
cette demande là est allé à davantage de
loi peut-être citoyenne alors il ya un
besoin de participation une envie de
participation oui peut-être des
nouvelles formules sur le droit de
pétition sur certains types de
référendum y compris des référendums
locaux il ya plein de choses à l'étude
je parlais du conseil économique social
et environnemental tout à l'heure je
vous rappelle que c'est la chambre de la
partie il est censé devenir la chambre
de la participation citoyenne il teste
des choses je pense qu'il ya des choses
à trouver il ya des réglages à faire
parler de la proportionnelle mois pour
moi c'est évident qu'il faut introduire
une dose de part de proportionnelle à
l'assemblée et est une promesse
2017 vous trouvez normal ça a été une
promesse de tous les candidats ce qui
est quand même extraordinaire dans la
présidentielle dans tous les candidats
vous trouvez 2017 vous ayez les deux
finalistes qui était et macron les
marine le pen qui sont finalistes de la
présidentielle avec des scores jeu puis
en tête mais qui sont quand même non
négligeable et qu'à l'arrivée un mois
après au législatif vous ayez la
république en marche qui est une
majorité écrasante avec 315 députés et
leur assemblée nationale qui est même
pas de quoi former un groupe il ya
quelque chose qui va pas du tout ça
fonctionne pas donc évidemment qu'il ya
des choses à changer mais je crois qu'il
faut aussi rester lucide et se dire que
la démocratie représentative
c'est quelque chose qui fonctionne vous
évoquiez les gilet jaune on a vu aussi
ce que ça donne c'est à dire qu'à partir
d'un moment du moment où chacun se dit
ma voix compte plus que tout je ne veux
surtout pas être représentés et il faut
tout changer mais personne ne peut
parler à ma place je suis désolé c'est
juste totalement ingérable ça ne
fonctionne pas je voudrais qu'on termine
par deux choses vote blanc vote
obligatoire parce que vote obligatoire
se dévoile le coup de massue le moyen
ultime pour pour finir avec l'abstention
mais déjà le vote blanc aujourd'hui il
n'est pas comptabilisé dans les
suffrages exprimés la veille une demande
massive des français vous le confirme et
où il ya une demande massive de
reconnaître de votre blanc mais qui est
lié un petit peu à ce qu'on disait tout
à l'heure c'est à dire que le vote blanc
considéré comme je dirais là le message
du mécontentement des français kim est
parti là dedans qui ne voudrait pas
finalement l'exprimer au regard d'un
candidat mais je voudrais exprimer du
coup dans un vote blanc qui soit par
conséquent reconnu vous savez pourquoi
on le fait pas pourquoi c'est si
compliqué c'est la peur d'un d'un vote
blanc majoritaire dans le pays oui je
pense qu'il ya des craintes de 2,2 de
part et d'autre je pense
qu'effectivement la la question de la
légitimité après de la personne et lui
se pose inévitablement et à ce moment là
il faut repenser le mode le mode de
scrutin donc la reconnaissance du vote
blanc c'est pas juste reconnaître un
principe est une petite enveloppe c'est
aussi reconsidérer un mode de scrutin
qui engagent des conséquences au sens
constitutionnel non négligeable j'aurais
juste permettre de rajouter quelque
chose sur la question de l'équipement de
l'éducation civique et politique dans le
livre la fracture on le remarque et on
le souligne il y a aujourd'hui un
intérêt de la jeunesse a pour la
politique et je pense que ce qui se joue
aujourd'hui c'est que cet intérêt là
n'est pas accompagnée dans les études
d'opinion entre l'ensemble des élections
lorsque vous faites des baromètre de
notoriété que ce soit des idées des
réformes des lois du personnel politique
vous avez une absence aujourd'hui de
réponses des jeunes qui est étonnante
vous avez des jeunes aujourd'hui qui ne
suivent pas la politique et infiniti
intéresse pas et je pense qu'il ya
effectivement une éducation à la vie
politique à la vie civique qui doit être
mené dans ce dans ce pays là un dernier
petit mot sur le sur le vote obligatoire
bonne ou mauvaise solution d'autres pays
l'ont fait je crois que ça mais je crois
que le type de la fausse bonne idée
vous ne comprenez plus haut qu'à faire
quelque chose donc vous voulez pas le
faire et vous pensez régler le problème
en disant on était obligé de le faire
franchement c'est ne pas s'attaquer aux
racines du mal c'est faire semblant de
faire voter les gens alors que c'est pas
comme ça c'est le contraire d'une
certaine façon dans le documentaire vous
avez cités il ya quelques jeunes qui
disent ça sera encore pire parce qu'ils
veulent nous s'ils veulent nous obliger
alors ça c'est la pire des méthodes là
fausses bananes et donc on verra rendez
vous après la présidentielle donc un
pour voir si ce chantier vraiment
prioritaire tout doit être remise à plat
on vous a bien entendu merci messieurs
merci d'être venus débattre de cette
abstention dont on verra si elle bat ses
records ou pas dimanche soir prochain on
va à présent accueillir notre grand
témoin il est historien académiciens
aujourd'hui les consacrés par la
collection bouquins qui publient une
large partie de son oeuvre la plus
politique des écrits qui s'étale sur
plus de 40 ans rassemblés sous ce titre
ce côté obscur du peuple titre qui
résonne évidemment particulièrement avec
l'actualité la guerre en ukraine et la
possible victoire des populistes à la
présidentielle on a plein de questions à
poser à basses calories comme les skis
ce sujet de thibaut enac
si on vous invite pascal ory c'est qu'il
arrive qu'un historien soit d'actualité
et c'est le cas en ce moment dans vos
travaux entrent en résonance avec la
situation politique alors que 38% des
français s'estiment capables de voter
pour marine le pen le populisme est il
aux portes du pouvoir en tout cas dans
cette élection et avant même d'avoir
parlé le peuple est depuis plusieurs
semaines sur toutes les bouches et pour
moi le peuple c'est des hommes et femmes
ils sont aujourd'hui perdu ils courent
dans tous les sens comme après le
passage d'un tsunami
moi je dis au peuple de droite révolte à
vous révoltez vous contre un scénario
écrit d'avancé par emmanuel macron à
vous de faire le printemps du peuple
rodez est
confisqué par les juges au vélo
[Applaudissements]
cette appropriation du peuple par la
politique pascal ory vous la connaissez
bien l'historien professeur émérite des
universités à la sorbonne membre de
l'académie française que vous êtes en a
longuement étudié les figures à travers
l'histoire il en retrouve aujourd'hui
les rouages il est évident que le non
conformisme d'un zemmour qui dit mais
attend d eux justement il ya un
consensus et bien moi je me distingue du
consensus ça peut être très efficace
pour se positionner comme celui qui ne
se laisse pas avoir par l'institution
c'est toujours d'idées qui insiste m
alors le système il est institutionnel
politique mais il est aussi culturel
historiographique le système et vous
aurez toujours dans les sociétés
contemporaines une partie de la société
on pourrait réunir dans une société de
ressentiment me qu'il n'écoutera surtout
pas mais alors pascal ory ce peuple si
chéri de nos candidats qui est il un
objet indéfinissable dites vous mais
d'autant plus facilement manipulable à
ce titre votre analyse des mouvements
fascistes et populiste vous fait
démonter quelques idées reçues le peuple
dit vous n'est pas nécessairement l'ami
des libertés le peuple peut être
autoritaire
il peut être identitaire sinophobe il
est radical is able
au final le peuple concluez vous et ce
au nom de quoi on prend le pouvoir alors
pascal ory vous qui avez suivi cette
campagne avec l'oeil de l'historien
risquez vous à quelques oracle le fruit
est il mur le populisme peut-il
l'emporter à ces élections nos
démocraties sont tels malades et si l'on
veut être optimiste
d'où pourrait venir leur salut à
l'avenir
bonsoir pascal ory bonsoir et merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous alors ce fil
rouge qui court à travers vos écrits
rassemblés dans cette très belle
collection la collection bouquins on l'a
compris c'est celle du du peuple la
question du peuple c'est une question je
tiens à ce mot parce que vous montrez
bien à travers les périodes sur lesquels
vous avez travaillé et qui sont
rassemblés dans le livre la
collaboration l'expérience fasciste de
nombreuses expériences de radicalité
d'extrême droite comme d'extrême gauche
que ce mot deux peuples et bien tout le
monde l'emploi à tord et à travers
jusqu'à aujourd'hui la veille de
l'élection présidentielle ce mot là il
est extrêmement ambiguë pourquoi il est
urgent de se pencher sur ce mot là
aujourd'hui
c'est évidemment lié à l'essor de ce
qu'on a appelé finalement de populisme
mais qui dans le cas de la france qui a
été très fondatrice pour cette figure là
le nationalisme la fin du 19e siècle
général boulanger c'est déjà un parti
complètement populiste avec déjà une
convergence entre l'extrême droite et
l'extrême gauche autour de ce fameux
général boulanger bon d'accord c'était
d'actualité monsieur viktor orban vient
d'être réélu sans difficulté on peut
toujours essayer d'aller voir si les
élections se sont déroulées de façon
tout à fait transparente mais enfin bon
monsieur maudit la plus grande
démocratie du monde c'est l'indre si on
considérait que démocratie on y
reviendra sans doute c'est synonyme de
démocratie libérale il a été réélu sans
problème
2010neuf monsieur maudit donc clairement
les populistes ne sont pas un
épiphénomène
représente dans une démocratie
représentative
une bonne partie du fameux peuple et
pour le reste il se trouve que depuis
maintenant quelques siècles la
souveraineté populaire c'est la base la
justification de tous nos régimes bien
une exception giresse et l'arabie
séoudite dont on finit par oublier
qu'elle est sur une autre planète
là on est dans la légitimité d'ancien
régime c'est une famille musulmane
famille propriétaire de mai tous les
c'est vrai que la souveraineté populaire
le peuple fondre les démos as absolument
mais même la corée du nord même l'iran
quand vous regardez la constitution
iranienne on voit très bien que c'est
une constitution moderne qui dit que le
peuple iranien a renversé un despote qui
était le chat donc la souveraineté
populaire est évidente sauf que la
démocratie si on considère qu'elle peut
se définir et je suis d'accord avec sap
comme le lieu de l'expression de la
souveraineté populaire
rien ne dit qu'elles produisent de la
liberté même de l'égalité la démocratie
peut être libéral quand c'est la
démocratie libérale faisons un peu de
lieux communs mais la démocratie peut
être autoritaire
viktor orban ce serait ça vladimir
poutine est peut être totalitaire chine
populaire c'est une démocratie
totalitaire elles ont trouvé ça
scandaleux il faudrait peut-être
réfléchir oui c'est ça c'est que les
démocraties peuvent aspirer à la
dictature c'est ce que vous montrez
d'autres dans votre ouvrage ce drôle de
mot de peuvent vous parler de drôle
d'entités c'est pas les classes
populaires c'est pas la nation est ce
que c'est une fiction ce mode peuple
bien utile pour ceux qui l'emploient
c'est une fiction comme tout principe
fondateur d'institutions politiques
depuis l'antiquité sauf que la fiction
change dieu c'est quand même un peu
éclipsé de la plupart de ces fictions là
mais ces fictions ce ne sont pas des
illusions c'est un personnage doté d'un
certain nombre de qualités j'irai supra
supra collective peut être suprême n et
qui est surtout c'est que le mot
essentiel souverain et ça c'est un c'est
un mot dont on ne comprend plus
aujourd'hui conscience c'est absolument
capital la souveraineté est
consubstantielle à tous les systèmes
politiques après on peut discuter de la
forme de souveraineté il faut plus de
démocratie participative et 7 heures
c'est une tentation dans laquelle on se
trouve vous verriez aujourd'hui en
france le peuple être autoritaire
identitaire conduire à la dictature
justifier la xénophobie il n'en reste
pas moins le peuple c'est ce que vous
écrivez ce que c'est une tentation on a
l'impression parfois qu'on est au bord
du précipice et qu'il ya une forme de
jouissance aussi à se sentir comme ça
prêt à tomber collectivement
il faut faire intervenir de la
psychologie dans l'analyse non seulement
des sociétés mais des individus et
pendant un certain temps par exemple à
sciences politiques a été complètement
indifférente à la dimension
psychologique elle a été complètement
indifférente à une une notion qui est
capitale pour comprendre par exemple le
mouvement populiste mais pas seulement
qui est l'émotion l'émotion bien entendu
pour la science politique traditionnelle
pour l'histoire politique traditionnelle
nous avions des acteurs rationnels
qui allaient voter ou qui n'avaient pas
voté mais qu'elle est plutôt voté dans
un système désormais de démocratie
libérale
ou est ce qu'on a vu ça bien entendu que
l'irrationnel entre guillemets que
l'émotionnel sont absolument déterminant
max weber avait été un des premiers à
dire qu'il ya un pouvoir charismatique
mais le pauvre michael bay il est mort
juste au moment où il disait mais bien
sûr ce pouvoir charismatique existe mais
c'est le passé il avait quasiment adolf
hitler sous la main c'est passionnant
parce que l'historien que vous êtes
s'intéresse aux faits et aux effets et
pas forcément aux causes et donc on
découvre même si on le redécouvre que
nos démocraties elles peuvent ne pas
aimer la liberté et à beaucoup de
chapitres consacrés à l'expérience
fasciste qui montre aussi que
l'expérience mussolini c'est la jonction
entre l'extrême droite et l'extrême
gauche la fameuse convergence rouge brun
là encore est ce que l'histoire nous
alerte sur les temps présents alors je
suis de ceux je désespère où je met en
fureur beaucoup de collègues qui pensent
que l'histoire n'enseigne rien au sens
où on disait même déjà dans l'antiquité
vous savez mieux connaître l'histoire ça
permet de moraliser le présent mais où
est ce que tu as vu la vérification de
ça absolument pas les sociétés sont
toujours dans le présent et elle renvoie
les historiens au passé en disant
écoutez bon je vous donne un exemple
dans le vote populiste et en particulier
xénophobes en france comme ailleurs il
ya pas mal de descendants d'immigrés
mais quelle immigrés je vais être un peu
lourd espagnol
thüga italien et quand on leur dit mais
ya peut-être une contradiction il faut
dire mais vous n'avez pas confondre mais
mes grands-parents avec les immigrés
d'aujourd'hui d'autant que l'histoire ne
n'en saigne rien fondamentalement en
revanche est fascinant pour comprendre
pour comprendre comprendre les ressorts
voilà et peut-être même coup alors là je
veux un peu audacieux pour aller vers
une compréhension du du lendemain
peut-être pas du surlendemain mais du
sud vit lendemain alors justement les
pokémon de marine le pen et celui de
jean luc mélenchon vous diriez que ils
ont des points communs alors je suis de
ceux qui ne mettraient pas le
qualificatif populisme à la gauche
radicale je crois que la gauche radicale
a une dimension autoritaire qui permet
des glissements vers le populisme ce qui
m'intéresse plus tôt c'est un électorat
qui est capable c'est l'électorat donc
c'est le peuple de rejeter peut-être à
quelques mois un jour d'intervalle pour
l'extrême gauche pour l'extrême droite
ce qui quand ils m'ont extrême c'est le
mot radical en revanche pour moi
techniquement le populisme est
automatiquement l'extrême droite même si
on ne fait jamais de meilleur populiste
qu'avec des gens qui viennent de la
gauche mais il se situe
fonctionnellement à l'extrême droite
puisque c'est une droite radicale dans
un style de gauche radicale parce que
dira le peuple dira la nation dire eux
les élites trahissent sa l'extrême
droite c'est très bien le dire ça venait
de la gauche
et le retour de la guerre en europe
alors je veux pas que vous fassiez des
analogies vous des passerelles etc mais
c'est quand même incroyable parce qu'on
a le sentiment qu'on a un peuple ou
l'éveil d'une nation qui résiste et qui
au fond demande d'une démocratie à cette
fois-ci là pour les ukrainiens on n'est
pas dans la tentation autoritaire
clairement on est en démocratie libérale
la volonté d'entrer dans dans l'europe
et dans l'otan et de l'autre côté
vladimir poutine qui est prêt à aller
jusqu'au bout quitte à tout perdre c'est
un peu le sentiment qu'on a aujourd'hui
est ce que est ce que vous y voyez
une sorte de retour de l'histoire c'est
le retour au 19e siècle pour simplifier
parce que le 19e siècle était un temps
où le national était quand même une
référence d'ailleurs il était une
puissance montante face aux vieux empire
supposé vermoulu etc et puis d'autres
pas la géopolitique c'est une
géopolitique de lutte entre des logiques
nationales et des logiques impérial ça
ressemble beaucoup à ce que nous vivons
en ce moment à côté de ça les sociétés
ont changé moi ce qui me frappe c'est
que nous sommes dans des sociétés qui
n'ont jamais été alors c'est un mot qui
n'est pas assez prononcées
individualiste par exemple quand on
s'interroge comme dans la première
partie de votre mission c'était tout à
fait passionnant sur l'absence
abstention etc il ya quand même un des
éléments pas le seul mais un des
éléments d'explication qui est nous
sommes au sommet pour l'instant ça ira
peut-être au-delà je ne sais pas j'ai
pas là pour le coup prophète de
l'individualisme donc dans un système
individualiste quel est le candidat qui
est parfait c'est moi même wen réponse
narcisse voilà vous aurez constaté que
c'est difficile de trouver un candidat
pourtant il ya douze candidats aux
présidentielles françaises qui soit moi
même ouais et un autre mot qu'on
retrouve énormément dans ce livre c'est
une réflexion sur la catastrophe le mot
de catastrophe il est très présent quand
on évoque le réchauffement climatique
est ce que l'historien que vous êtes
pense que la démocratie n'est pas en
mesure ou pas complètement en mesure de
relever ce défi alors je suis de ceux
qui pensent mais confondant sur des
expériences historiques donc je
maintiens je suis quand même pas
prophète que ya aucune raison de penser
que si la prophétie écologistes quand je
dis prophétie s'est pas du tout un
jugement de valeur négatif c'est un
constat l'écologie politique a qu'une
dimension religieuse c'est clair vous
avez des prix ciao si cette prophétie à
vérifier est on vraiment certain que
cela va développer des réflexes
premièrement mondialiste et deuxièmement
de démocratie participative
on pourrait en douter et au contraire
penser que s'il y a le feu au lac berne
en parler moi l'expression alors à un
régime autoritaire iter évidemment avec
des personnalités charismatiques qui
demanderont à ce que tout le monde fasse
bloc autour d'eux donc on peut appeler
ça du populisme il est des leçons dans
l'histoire qu'on peut tirer tout de même
comme je pense profondément l'histoire
est tragique les leçons sont tragiques
c'est à dire que roméo et juliette pour
rester ensemble ils se suicident bon un
pays pour régler ces problèmes
entre en guerre civile voyez donc ce
sont des solutions qui sont pires que le
problème ce sont les solutions et
l'histoire est pleine de situations
tragiques qu'il peut y avoir peut-être
on verra une aspiration alors est ce que
ça leur a peut-être peut-être c'est le
brin de paille qui brille au fond d'eux
les tables je suis vers le nom merci
infiniment de calories vous restez avec
nous je rappelle le titre c'est c'est
comment dire une somme une consécration
parce que c'est très prestigieux la
collection bouquins vous avez écrit
beaucoup de préface dans d'autres dans
la même collection pour d'autres mais
aujourd'hui c'est vous pascal ory ce
côté obscur du peuple c'était important
de vous entendre aussi à quelques jours
du premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle alors on va passer au
scan à présent va continuer à parler
démocratie d'une certaine manière la
campagne passée au crible de nos
chroniqueurs 7,8
mais avant d'être il y a les deux bras
de fatalité au grand remplacement et
bien moi je vous propose le round mort
d'agir pour le climat l'assimilation
la république c'est moi la prendre
orange ma chronique
travailleuses et travailleurs
le système vous exclus il ya un vrai
problème de pouvoir d'achat rendre à la
france sa grandeur d'arriver à sa prime
histoire c'est le vol
et ils nous ont rejoints sur ce plateau
trois journalistes ce soir richard
wehrli la campagne vu de l'étranger dans
un instant ça nous intéresse apparemment
il ya un petit décalage
brandon ouaret bonsoir merci d'être avec
nous à nous parler de l'ultime efforts
que font les petits candidats oui on les
appelle comme ça dans cette dans cette
campagne on commence avec vous c'était
femmes le carnet de campagne l'oeil de
blacko attiré par qui et par quoi ce
soir et bien c'est le dernier jour de la
campagne du premier tour presque le
dernier jour donc là on tire ses
dernières cartouches donc il s'agit de
bien viser chaque candidat voyez ils
cherchent à atteindre son principal
rival donc par exemple pour van luc
mélenchon la cible en ce moment c'est
marine le pen et l'angle d'attaqué de
jean luc mélenchon c'est bien sûr de
faire le bilan du quinquennat de marine
le pen vous comprenez le bilan du
quinquennat oui parce que là elle
réclame le mandat suprême mais il ya
cinq ans on revient un autre mandat le
mandat de député quel est ce que l'on a
fait ce mandat est ce qu'elles étaient
présentes à l'assemblée à l activation
est souvent en écho jean luc mélenchon
sur la proposition de loi qui proposait
de donner le rsa aux jeunes gens de 18 à
25 ans
il y aura comme vous le savez un
dispositif madame le pen parce qu'elle
est madame
devrait avoir une sensibilité plus aigu
sur certaines questions eh ben non
absente lors de l'examen de la loi
contre les violences faites aux femmes
en décembre 2019
elle sait y faire en meeting jean luc
mélenchon en attendant marine le pen
troisième campagne il serait temps de l
d'evans elle devance toujours méluche
dans les sondages mais oui parce que
depuis le début de la campagne elle a
dit que sa priorité c'était le pouvoir
d'achat alors ça tombe bien parce que
c'est la préoccupation numéro un des
français donc forcément bas la france
est soumise on essaie de dire nous aussi
on est des champions du pouvoir d'achat
et donc ce matin tests comparatifs pour
adrien catelet parmi ceux qui nous
écoutent chez ceux qui ont des voisins
des collègues des amis de la famille qui
pour une raison qui nous échappe pense
que madame le pen va s'occuper du
pouvoir d'achat et des petites gens et
quand on regarde son programme on se dit
mais pourquoi vous croyez ça vous fait
berner si vous pensez que cette femme va
soucier de votre pouvoir d'achat voilà
si vous voulez l'augmentation du smic
c'est avec jean luc mélenchon si vous
voulez la retraite à 60 ans c'est avec
jean lui passent et avec qui
on a bien compris mélenchon comme sur le
pen pécresse elle turquie alors là c'est
assez spectaculaire parce que valérie
pécresse dès qu'on lui pose une question
elle flingue immédiatement mâcon valoir
ce matin invité sur ses news laurence
ferrari lui pose la question de base
fait le composent à tous les candidats
ont l'écoutent quel serait votre
première mesure en matière de pouvoir
d'achat et bien évidemment la
réindexation des retraites est
prioritaire et d'ailleurs je vois qu
emmanuel macron a entendu l'opposition
sur cette question parce que nos
retraités sont les grands sacrifiés de
ce quinquennat je vous promets elle ne
peut pas parler 10 secondes sans dire du
mal des modèles macron qu'est ce que
vous proposez pour l'énergie et le rdp
création la principale chose qu'il faut
faire c'est changer de politique
énergétique emmanuel macron a commis que
des erreurs durant tout son quinquennat
et notamment celle de fermer fessenheim
je vous ai trop sa rapidité mais elle a
aussi un projet sur les retraites à 1
valérie pécresse
sur la réforme des retraites manuel
macron a dit qu'il allait faire la
réforme des retraites et puis soudain il
ya quelques jours il nous a dit ce ne
sera pas la priorité de mon quinquennat
rien sur les migrations
suspecte mais bien sûr qu'elle en a
parlé des gens en écoute vous
savez hier j'étais à aubervilliers
j'étais à aubervilliers avec ces
associations de femmes qui sont obligées
de taguer sur les trottoirs place aux
femmes qui sont obligées d'afficher dans
les cafés ici les femmes sont bienvenus
voilà la de la mode et maniérisme voilà
la république d'emmanuel macro laisser
les laisser là dire du mal de manacor
effectivement très très remonté et oui
on se demande comment elle va faire pour
appeler à voter macron dès le soir du
premier tour bon cela dit si sarkozy
appelle à voter macron ce que nie
pécresse on s'en fout un petit peu mais
un scoring variable il faut quand même
penser je savais qu'au ps on pense aux
deux déjà au second tour il ya eu une
réunion secrète hier soir entre anne
hidalgo martine aubry et françois
hollande bon cela dit dès que françois
lang et dans une réunion il n'est pas
secrète il y avait un article dans le
monde d'aujourd'hui pour prévenir de
cette réunion secrète le problème c'est
que ce matin la porte parole du ps était
chez apolline de malherbe qui qui n'est
pas commode fuir la pauvreté comme un
lapin dans les phares n'a pas prévu le
coup et ce n'est pas cette réunion t
c'est un peu compliqué de commenter
cette actualité là en plus on est
effectivement trois jours quatre jours
d'un premier tour des élections
présidentielles qui est quand même
important donc parce que ce serait bon
qu'on se concentre bon on sent votre
votre malaise sur cette question là mais
ça valait le coup de se lever à 6h30
pour se faire engueuler mais c'est comme
ça en tout cas ni la gohelle elle fait
semblant de rien elle pense qu'elle peut
toujours arriver au second tour et elle
fonce elle répond aux interviews comme
s'il est en meeting en fait si vous êtes
européen républicain laïc écologiste et
sociale vous votez anne hidalgo vous ne
votez pas jean-luc mélenchon et votez
votez pour vos convictions et voilà on
continue à les croire à l'éloge de
blacko c'est chaque soir dans ça vous
regarde on va continuer à parler de la
campagne avec vous brandon alors vous
vous nous parlez de l'ultime stratégie
c'est ça des petits candidats
effectivement j'ai analysé lors leur
dernière intervention et j'ai remarqué
qu'ils avaient tous un point commun plus
on se rapproche de l'élection
présidentielle du premier tour et plus
les petits candidats bas dépolitise lors
discours on a aussi un an jean lassalle
c'est le plus le plus le plus
particulier un candidat authentique qui
depuis quelques semaines parle de moins
en moins politique mais davantage de
polémiquer coûté le vous créiez après
informer
et vous attendez un fort mais en
permanence c'est une forme de propagande
terrifiant qui s'est mise sur pied on
connaissait le chanteur malheureux voici
le candidat malheureux
oui justement très une gestuelle très
présente et durant ce mythique de deux
heures au départ on avait vu un candidat
qui était une avec une voix très posée
très calme n'oubliez presse qu'il
s'agissait d'un meeting et justement
avec cette séquence on voit jean
lassalle nerveux très complotistes avec
cette gestuelle très appuyé et c'est
d'ailleurs le seul moment c'est très
intéressant le seul moment où il prend
un ton très autoritaire est très rigide
on a vraiment l'impression qu'il subit
la compagnie et on retrouve cette
stratégie fait d'autres candidats c'est
le cas notamment de nathalie arthaud qui
est très lucide ans dans le rôle qu'elle
occupe durant cette campagne écoutez la
scission n'est pas qu'elle préside on
sortira du chapeau la question est de
savoir si les travailleurs réussiront ou
non à s'organiser ma candidature est un
appel à la conscience et à la
mobilisation
kenneth heyer tôt nous fait comprendre
qu'elle ne se présente pas pour être élu
président de la république elle utilise
la présidentielle comme un porte voix
pour appeler à faire la révolution en
outrepassant mon dieu on ne fait pas
sans forcément ses électeurs elle ne
dirige pas justement vers les urnes et
on a justement un discours très
particulier avec un verbe habituel c'est
sa marque de fabrique une candidate
constamment sur l'offensive et d'autres
coins de candidats vont même encore plus
loin en se portant candidat il y en a
très peu qui l'ont fait en se préparant
réellement à devenir président de la
république et ses 4 philippe vous trouve
écoutez le l'exil élections paraît foiré
elle paraît à me sers du nom mais des
habituels mans à votre place on me dit
qu'on croit pas les sondages vous vous
dites que vous les croyez elles sont
assez a priori en petit photographique
mais philippe poutou ne fait même plus
semblant il fait un constat d'échec et
il est légitime forcément se demander à
quoi sert la candidature de philippe
poutou je ne vais pas être président
mais je vais quand même taclé ainsi les
tanks et sept autres personnes forcément
à partir de ce moment là c'est un
candidat qui qui dénonce mais aussi ça
c'est très intéressant c'est son rire
jaune à la fin de son discours il est
aussi révélateur d'une capitulation d'un
candidat battu avant même le combat des
urnes à l'arrêt c'est lui c'est le
troisième tour dans la rue la prévenir
c'est la lutte dans les entreprises
alors les petits candidats avec ses
petits candidats on se rend compte que
la campagne prend aussi des allures de
culture du buzz il ya un réel
détournement l'élection présidentielle
avec un objectif forcément se démarquer
le plus possible de ses adversaires il
ya là mais ce que vous connaissez la
série espagnole la casa des papes elle
alors je présente du coup la version
française c'est la casa des roussel et
oui vous verrez c'est une sauce
communiste assez original regardez c'est
l'argent de nos richesses et bien cet
argent aurait nous retrouver dans le
progrès social dans les services publics
dans notre pouvoir d'achat rendez nous
notre argent
pour nous qu'à du besoin la campagne
présidentielle un fabien au sel sur son
élévateur qui profitent justement de sa
fonction avec son écharpe points comme
si l'incarner à lui seul la république
est ce qui est très intéressant cette
séquence par antonomase on voit que
l'élévateur représente ici le symbole du
pouvoir l'elysée son écharpe bas celui
qui incarne le pouvoir est forcément
devant lui un ses militants qui sont
déguisés en braqueurs de banque qui
représente métaphoriquement forcément
ses adversaires politiques et chasse de
la bourse devait avoir
ça vous surprend vous à présence de deux
candidats d'extrême gauche dans cette
campagne c'est une tradition française
quand de la caution dont beaucoup de
pays quand même mais juste la trotskiste
les trotskistes ont l'habitude des 2 3 4
deux factions de fractions dans ces
groupuscules parce que c'est c'est 0 5%
c'est c'est quand même que
ça en est loin je crois que depuis
sérieusement est-ce que cette campagne
ou non campagne c'est quand même une
campagne très particulière elle va elle
va avoir des conséquences à votre avis
de toute façon il ya comme une sorte de
le sentiment que le débat n'a pas eu
lieu où vous croyez pas du tout à ça je
crois pas du tout à ça je pense qu'il ya
effectivement je ne citais tout à
l'heure un phénomène fondamental qui
l'individualisme qui arrive à des
sommets qui fait que la supposée
indifférence est liée à des
représentations évidemment négative du
collectif mais c'est parce que nous
n'avons
mais la possibilité alors qu'il ya douze
candidats douze candidats de trouver un
candidat qui nous ressemble c'est le
consommateur qui remplace citoyens
seront ravis d'être satisfait il ya un
peu de ça ap puis comme nous sommes ici
dans une
chaîne qui s'appelle la chaîne
parlementaire je voudrais quand même
rappeler aux français puis à ceux qui
débattent que il après les élections
présidentielle et les élections
législatives et ça c'est très français
c'est très monarchie républicaine de se
focaliser sur les présidentielles mais
imaginez que une candidate populiste
soit élu au second tour des
présidentielles il est très
vraisemblable que la couleur dominante
de la santé sera pas tout à fait
d'autres actions de blocage sous les
yeux des yeux du monde grâce à ça on va
attendre d'abord dimanche mais
effectivement ce scénario ne nous a pas
échappé c'est un scénario pour le moment
richard alors vous vous allez nous
parler un peu de la campagne vue de la
presse étrangère il ya beaucoup de
reportages en ce moment de vos collègues
je rappelle que vous êtes le
correspondant du quotidien suisse à
paris du quotidien suisse le temps et la
sidèrent la colère anti macro
apparemment alors oui effectivement
c'est véritablement là dessus que
beaucoup de médias étrangers s'interroge
comment pourquoi autant de colère contre
le président de la république d'autant
que celui-ci on l'avait déjà dit ici a
plutôt une bonne image vu de l'étranger
il pour son pour son bilan et pour ce
qu'il a fait alors il ya une ville que
les médias étrangers aiment bien leur
cette ville ce n'est pas marseille ou
lille vous savez quand on est
correspondant marseille ou lille c'est
parfait marseille c'est exotique ses
lointains c'est méridionale lille c'est
pas loin à une heure de train donc en
général c'est les villes qu'on visite
mais il y en a une autre qui a surgi ces
saint-etienne saint-etienne où le
'financial times s'est rendu à la fin
mars tout comme le temps mon propre
journal mais ce n'est pas moi qui ai
fait le papier parce que saint-etienne
c'est bien sûr manufrance et l'héritage
c'est le symbole footballistique
glorieux des verts etc il y avait aussi
beaucoup de gilet jaune sur les rompre
un sur les ronds-points pardon en 2018
2019 or voici que le financial times qui
a trouvé autre chose est d'ailleurs le
titre est repris par un supplément de
courrier international que je vous
recommande c'est la cocotte minute voilà
à saint-etienne on voit
ir la lutte française et dans ce
bouillon politique eh bien il ya un
homme qui ressort criblé de critiques
c'est l'actuel locataire de l'elysée
alors el país le quotidien espagnol lui
parle effectivement d'un président en
difficulté et il voit dans la sphère
mckinsey café récente vous savez qu'une
enquête a été ouverte et bien une
polémique plus qu'inopportune selon son
correspondant marque bassett qui évoque
le sentiment d'un on en a parlé en
france aussi d'un président trop proche
des milieux d'affaires parce que dans ce
pays en france selon el país on est
toujours autant passionné d'égalité
c'est les mêmes interrogations
finalement effectivement c'est les mêmes
interrogations c'est cette idée que la
colère elle est peut-être plus mû par un
espèce de sentiment national français
une psychologie comme le dirait pascal
ory que par véritablement des raisons
précises alors mckinsey où mac macro
parce que mc macron c'était le slogan de
jean luc mélenchon a lille on en a vu un
esprit de thaler et j'étais à ce meeting
voilà alors il ya une chose c'est vrai
ça donnera mais l'enfant exactement
alors il ya une chose qui frappe les
médias étrangers c'est que il ya une
peur qui flottent en france et cette
peur pour le quotidien de turin la
stampa c'est la pauvre adèle sort passe
haut la peur du grand dépassement du
grand surpassement les français ont peur
finalement on appelle ça aussi le grand
des classements en france que quelque
chose va les ensevelir et qu'ils ne
seront peut-être plus maîtres de leur
destin alors il y a d'autres journaux
qui en parle il ya le new york times qui
parle de marine le pen avec un mot très
intéressant alors je vais dire le titre
en anglais french élections opens up as
marine le pen se disent la soeur vous
vous souvenez de ce terme on l'utilisé
en irak ou en afghanistan
la soeur de l'armée américaine est bien
pour le new york times il y a une soeur
geely à une poussée en faveur de marine
le pen mais il ya quand même une
correspondante qui aime la france et qui
aime sa capacité à contredire les
fatalistes c'est michaela wiegel
d'excellentes correspondant de la
frankfurter allgemeine zeitung donc on
va voir dimanche si les français
contredisent une fois de plus les
fatalistes
les belges votre mac rond ah oui vous
l'apprenez merci merci et beaucoup les
scanner merci pascal ory d'être passé
par le plateau d'accepter ce côté obscur
du peuple collection bouquins la partie
je dirais la plus politique de vos
écrits voilà de nombreux nombreux écrits
qui remonte à voilà quelques quelques
décennies c'est passionnant pour
comprendre aussi le temps présent très
belle soirée documentaire ce soit virus
regards de photographes qui raconte
comment cinq photographes ont travaillé
pendant l'épidémie très belle soirée et
demain
[Musique]